[Music]
have you ever come across a thought of
how easy it would be to shift to
autopilot mode during traffic or maybe a
car that drives on its own from location
a to location B hi guys welcome to this
video from simply learn and today I'm
going to take you on a tour of how
self-driving cars will change the future
this is Volvo's 360 C concept car and
it's just one idea of what completely
driverless cars might look like one day
that means cars without even a steering
wheel that can safely navigate public
roads entirely on their own but with how
much we hear about self-driving
technology making its way into everyday
cars it's hard not to wonder how much
longer do we have to wait
[Music]
companies like Google Tesla and / are
coming up with new ideas of innovation
for growth in technology in everyday
life in a recent report
Business Insider predicted that as many
as 10 million self-driving cars would be
on the road as early as 2020 Wang mu was
started by Google in the year 2009 Ramos
mission is to make it safe and easy for
people and things to move around it aims
to bring a fully self-driving technology
to the world for better transport and
mobility and since thousands of life due
to traffic crashes
according to reports there have been 1.3
5 million deaths in 2016 and 2.4 million
injuries in 2015 worldwide due to
vehicle crashes 2 out of 3 people are
involved in a drunk driving crash 3
million Americans age 40 and older are
blind or have low vision 79% of seniors
aged 65 and older live in car dependent
communities 42 hours are wasted in
traffic each year or person way more is
one of the self-driving cars the clicked
it started off into 2009 and in 2018
Waymon was launched in Phoenix
behind every giant leap are the steps it
took to get there from our first steps
as a moonshot project at Google to the
series of steps that led to this tech
self-driving cars don't just live in our
imaginations way mo is one step closer
to making our roads safer and easier to
navigate for all we're challenging the
impossible and paving the way toward a
better future
greenwall and Jaguar have gotten to
develop the world's first fully
self-driving Jaguar I face testing began
in 2018
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
self-driving cars will change the
mindset of people even at an individual
level these cars will forever change the
lives of the elderly and
differently-abled people by giving them
back their freedom even the restaurants
and hotels could face competition from
these autonomous cars where the
passengers may enjoy dining in or
sleeping in the moving vehicles
self-driving vehicles are going to
change the outlook of transportation and
will have a tremendous impact on
everything we do but with every
technology there will be some challenges
involved and once we overcome these
problems these travelers cars will make
our life simpler smarter and safer so
this was all about how self-driving cars
are going to change the future I hope
you guys enjoyed this video
do like and share it also subscribe to
our Channel and hit the bell icon thank
you for watching and stay tuned for more
from simply learn
[Music]